celebración y protesta de verde en santo
domingo cientos de personas de república
dominicana conmemoraron que la acampada
feminista frente al palacio nacional
lleva ya un mes reclamando la
legalización parcial del aborto las
activistas han pasado todas las noches
frente a la sede del ejecutivo y aunque
todavía no han logrado su objetivo final
aseguran que tienen motivos para
celebrar
hay dos cosas fundamentales la presión
que se ha ido dando en el movimiento de
mujeres y en el movimiento social
alrededor de esta problemática y otra es
la la persistente apoyo manifestación de
apoyo de la gente a este campamento el
reclamo es despenalizar la interrupción
del embarazo en tres causales si es
producto de una violación si la vida de
la mujer se encuentra en peligro o si el
feto no podrá vivir tras el parto las
activistas además reclaman al presidente
luís abinader que las apoye
especialmente frente a un congreso que
mayoritariamente se opone a esta reforma
del código penal
abinader ha asegurado repetidas veces de
estar a favor de despenalizar el aborto
en ocasiones muy concretas como en esta
entrevista con el país de diciembre de
2020 mire yo estoy en desacuerdo como lo
está la mayoría de la población no
solamente en la república dominicana
sino del mundo con el aborto libre pero
si pienso que tienen que haber causales
que permitan la interrupción del
embarazo
república dominicana es el país con la
tasa más alta de embarazo infantil y
adolescente del continente americano
pero las mujeres que opten por un aborto
pueden enfrentar ahí hasta 2 años de
prisión y los médicos que lo practiquen
hasta 20 años de cárcel